[Music]
on this Saturday night Reviving The Mask
debate overwhelmed hospitals and kids
icus over capacity putting the pressure
on politicians to restart mask mandates
it is a triple threat and really truly
shame on public health and on everybody
else for having waited and pharmacists
frustrated with the fragile supply of
children's pain meds
isolating China Canada's new
indo-pacific trade pledges on day one of
Trudeau's Southeast Asian tour those
opportunities are immense trade and
investment the U.S Senate race now neck
and neck the Democrats new pickup and
where the Republicans are asking Trump
to stay away and no stone left alone
living in France the sacrifices that
Canadians make is very very concrete and
touching the story of one Canadian
Soldier and a tiny French Village
global national with para Nasser
good evening thanks for joining us
pressure is mounting on elected
officials to bring back masks in Ontario
you may remember mandates were first
brought in to help overwhelmed and
overloaded hospitals well doctors say
that exact scene is now playing out at
Children's Hospitals pediatric icus are
operating above capacity add to that
severe Staffing shortages and the
so-called triple demick of covid-19
influenza and RSV as Camille carmale
reports with flu season just starting
Physicians are standing the alarm saying
it's just the beginning and warning of a
possible ripple effect across Canada
the crush of patience in Ontario's
Children's Hospitals unlike anything
doctors have ever seen before I've never
seen anything like this and the
situation is dire I mean where ICU beds
are basically non-existent government
sources now say Ontario's top doctor
will recommend the public begin masking
on Monday a recommendation but not a
mandate if there isn't a mandate a lot
of people are not going to be wearing
masks and that just makes things more
dangerous for everyone the triple threat
covid-19 influenza and respiratory
sensitial virus or RSV is overwhelming
Children's Hospitals the ICU at Toronto
sick kids is operating at more than 120
percent over capacity Children's
Hospital of eastern Ontario in Ottawa
has been forced to open a second
Intensive Care Unit and McMaster in
Hamilton is at an occupancy rate of 104
30 percent so as you can tell right here
this shelf right here it has dust on it
overflowing hospitals only exacerbated
by empty Pharmacy shelves Children's
Medicine in high demand that the
situation in hospital is destined to get
worse if we don't have the supplies
necessary to treat
patients in a community setting this is
the most urgent situation right now
there's nothing more important than your
children and doctors warn this is just
the beginning of the triple wave I
suspect that it will get worse before it
gets better again which is quite
concerning I think that there are things
that we can do as a society
um so the big thing is inter
reintroducing the mouse mandate
especially in schools the Ottawa Carlton
District School Board taking matters
into its own hands the new trustees will
be sworn in Tuesday and will immediately
vote to bring back masks in classrooms
shame on public health and on everybody
else for having waited until it was this
bad because we knew they hope it'll
spark other school boards to follow in
their footsteps and add to the mounting
pressure on the province to do the same
Kamel coromali Global News
prime minister Justin Trudeau has
announced 333 million dollars in new
funding aimed at deepening ties with
southeast Asia
Ottawa says it aims to shift trade away
from China Trudeau is in Cambodia
meeting with leaders of some of the
world's fastest growing economies
Global's Mackenzie gray is traveling
with the prime minister
it's all eyes on Asia for Justin Trudeau
with the Prime Minister touching down in
Phnom Penh for the asean summit
a warm welcome from the 10 member states
who Trudeau is trying to court as a part
of the liberal's new indo-pacific plan
this is a serious strategy that aims to
deepen and strengthen our engagement in
the region in the long term
putting asean at the center of our
strategy the focus of that engagement is
now taking shape with the Prime Minister
announcing nine separate initiatives
including establishing a trade Hub in
Southeast Asia money for a feminist
assistance policy fund and increasing
available scholarships to have South
Asians study in Canada this means more
jobs and more markets for Canadians and
it means more growth for asean at
countries that's the goal of the new
approach increased trade and relations
with friendly Asian countries to isolate
China with a combined GDP larger than
India's and a population of over 600
million asean members are prime targets
for the Liberals in the those
opportunities are immense and trade and
investment is going to be a Cornerstone
of our work in the indo-pacific strategy
in the days ahead the Prime Minister
will shift his attention from Asia to
the war in Ukraine when he meets with
other world leaders at the G20 Summit in
Indonesia one leader Justin Trudeau
won't see Vladimir Putin the Russian
president declined an invite to come to
Indonesia and has sent his foreign
minister Sergey lavrov instead summoned
foreign affairs minister Melanie Jolie
has no intention of meeting well we've
been here with Russia our goal is to
isolate Russia economically politically
and diplomatically but Jolie did meet
with the foreign affairs minister from
Ukraine and sources tell global news
that the prime ministers expected to
make announcements about additional
support for Ukraine later in the trip
Farah
Mackenzie gray reporting from Cambodia
thank you Mackenzie
shocking reports of alleged Chinese
interference in Canada's 2019 elections
have rocked the Trudeau government and
have raised questions about whether
Ottawa is doing enough to deal with the
threat from Beijing the opposition wants
a parliamentary committee to investigate
the allegations first reported by global
news investigative reporter Sam Cooper
our Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes
Stevenson will be taking a closer look
at the story and its implications for
National Security on this week's edition
of the West block Mercedes
thanks Farah the threat of potential
interference by Beijing in Canada isn't
new but the bombshell Revelations
reported last week by our Sam Cooper
take things to another level sources say
the intelligence Community is extremely
concerned by what China is doing and by
the liberal government's underwhelming
response in January prime minister
Trudeau and select members of his
cabinet allegedly received a series of
stunning briefings that included
allegations of everything from
interference in the 2019 election to
concerns about the intimidation of
Chinese Canadian communities and coerced
extraditions to China using so-called
Chinese police stations on Canadian soil
China experts we spoke to on the west
block say they aren't surprised that
Beijing has been upping the ante
Canada's former ambassador to China
David mulrooney found the recent
Revelations deeply troubling what's
astonishing about this latest report is
its size ambition and complexity to run
this through 11 different campaigns is
astounding to be able to do that and to
control it and I I think we need to be
taking a very deep deep look at what
China is doing to bring a threat to our
autonomy as a country to our ability to
operate independently National Security
expert Akshay Singh echoed those
concerns to me highlighting that there's
a lot at stake for Canada I think what's
new in these allegations is the depth of
what's happening in the extent to which
they're actually taking place in the
country I think one thing that Sam's
pointed out which I would like to uh
make sure that I point out as well is
that it's not just about elections also
on the show this week I'll speak with
veterans affairs minister Lawrence
McCauley who is in the hot seat as the
wait times for veterans disability
benefits continue to fail the promised
standard leaving veterans struggling and
I'll ask the minister about calls for
him to resign as well as his future and
the process has continued to come it's
not a success Mercedes it's not a
success but it's we're on the right
track and the only time it will be a
success is when we get to the National
Standard and not by next summer we
expect to have that vitally important
for veterans we'll have more on both of
those stories this week on the west
block pharah all right Mercedes
Stevenson thanks Mercedes in the U.S
control of the House and Senate is still
up in the air the house may swing back
to Republican control but the fate of
the Senate is waiting on the results of
a too close to call Race in Nevada and a
runoff in Georgia and as Jennifer
Johnson reports the man blamed for
Republican losses Donald Trump is
gearing up for his own battle against
Congress in a critical U.S Senate race
Arizona Democrat Mark Kelly is the
projected winner putting his party one
Victory away from controlling the senate
for the rest of President Joe Biden's
term and I'm so honored that Arizona has
entrusted me
to represent our state in the United
States Senate
Arizona's Republican gubernatorial
candidate has spread doubts about the
accuracy of the vote counting her race
is still a toss-up Arizona's largest
county America's second largest voting
jurisdiction is now undergoing a vote
audit we're not doing anything wrong at
all it's required under Arizona law and
this hand count audit allows us to
ensure that the machines are operating
correctly
another critical Senate race won't be
determined until December 6 when
Democrats Senator Rafael Warnock faces
off again against former football star
Herschel Walker the runoff was forced
after neither candidate got 50 percent
of the vote prominent Republicans are
already campaigning with Walker
but one big name Republican former
president Donald Trump is being asked to
stay away from the Walker campaign after
several candidates Trump endorsed lost
in the midterms GOP leaders have
reportedly grown tired of Trump's
controversies Trump has just filed suit
against the January 6 committee which
subpoenaed him to testify about his role
in the capital Riot Trump is keeping
quiet about that investigation ahead of
his own big news president Trump is
going to announce on Tuesday that he's
running for president and it's going to
be a very professional very buttoned up
announcement meanwhile Republicans do
seem poised to take over the house most
races still being counted are leaning
red what was our mission to win the
majority to stop Biden's agenda and fire
Nancy Pelosi but really stopping Biden's
agenda will require Republicans also
take over the Senate Jennifer Johnson
Global News Washington
melting ice opening up new waterways and
new problems in Canada's North coming up
the consequences of climate change when
it comes to security and safety in the
Arctic
Canada's Northern Frontier is changing
fast to say the Arctic has one of the
harshest climates of anywhere in the
world is nothing new but melting
glaciers and sea ice are making it even
more unpredictable and dangerous Jeff
Semple recently spent time on board one
of Canada's six new icebreakers part of
a mission to map new waterways and
maintain a firm presence in the region
as he reports communities in Canada's
far north hope the new federal funding
will help preserve their livelihoods
[Music]
grew up on these Waters off the coast of
a kaluit
his family fishes year round and they've
seen up close how climate change is
reshaping the region
he was hoping out there
he says the ice is melting earlier in
the year making the river less
predictable
scary area
last July his family's boat hit a clear
piece of ice when they hit that ice made
a hole
right there and there's no long crack we
were sticking so fast incredibly they
managed to climb onto a nearby sheet of
ice where they waited shivering for
hours until their friends came to the
rescue
we are alive we were very lucky to
survive the accident across Canada's
North the melting ice is opening up new
waterways to Maritime traffic from
fishing boats to cruise ships creating
an urgent need to police these Waters
and expand search and rescue
capabilities enter hmcs Margaret Brook
New course zero seven eight a minute
three five the Arctic vessel is the
newest addition to the Royal Canadian
Navy one of what will eventually be six
icebreakers tasked with patrolling
Canada's Northern Waters now we realize
that with the ice melting now there's
going to be more and more cargo ship
going to Northwest Passage it's it's
time for us to be there policing you
look outside the water is pristine make
sure that all environmental laws or show
a presence to patrol the Arctic an area
that covers 40 percent of Canada's
territory their best Lifeline is local
knowledge
Emily Joss is a member of the Sault Ste
Marie historic metis community and she
holds a newly created position within
the Navy indigenous liaison officer for
us it's an incredibly important
relationship the ship's Affiliated
territory is no naziobut the Inuit
Homeland in Labrador we just started our
relationship building with the
government and naziaba in the last six
months but it's already been incredibly
fruitful in terms of the local knowledge
of the areas that we're operating in
today we turn another page and begin
norad's next chapter last summer Ottawa
announced plans to spend 40 billion
dollars over the next 20 years to beef
up Canada's Northern defenses
following Russia's invasion of Ukraine
protecting the Arctic is very important
my only hope is that there are great
investments in the people and the
infrastructure support nunavut's NDP MP
says Northern Communities have long
suffered from poor internet connectivity
and a desperate lack of housing
most of the airports and fly-in
communities don't even have paved
runways Lori idlow hopes the new funding
will help to bridge the northern
infrastructure Gap these Investments I
think will largely end up going south
because of who will do the contracts and
the work how are you okay we put those
concerns directly to Canada's defense
minister can you tell us anything more
anything new about how that money will
be spent most definitely I was in Goose
Bay earlier this summer to make sure
that the members of the community there
knew that that is going to be one place
where we will be committing upgrades we
will continue to consult with our
indigenous Partners in the north and we
want to make sure that our indigenous
partners of this country can share in
the economic benefits that will unfold
as a result of these Investments
for those on the front lines of climate
change a potential win-win for Arctic
security and Northern development Jeff
Semple Global News a Callaway
[Music]
ahead finally something to celebrate in
Ukraine as Russia and its Retreat from a
key City
celebrations continued for ukrainians
this weekend as Russian troops announced
their withdrawal from Carson the
regional Capital President Vladimir
Putin said would belong to Russia
forever
foreign
er only lasted eight months ukrainians
in Odessa and across the country
celebrated the victory the defeat comes
as a major blow for Russia but Putin
still continues to pose a threat
retreating Russian troops blew up major
infrastructure in Curson Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski warned that
70 percent of the region remains under
Russian control
the world's most elusive graffiti artist
has unveiled a new mural in a small
Ukrainian Town scarred by War
Banksy painted a mural on a bombed out
building just outside Ukraine's capital
of a young girl doing a handstand on
Rubble
at least one other painting looks to be
in banksy's signature style showing a
man being grappled and flipped over by a
child
locals say the artworks are a symbol of
Ukraine's unity and resistance
[Music]
French villagers honor one of our own
the uniquely Canadian tribute 80 years
in the making
[Music]
foreign
program that connects a younger
generation to this country's war heroes
is expanding a small village in northern
France held its first no stone left
alone event this month a Canadian
Soldier was honored at his gravesite in
Normandy in a very Canadian way our
Europe bureau chief Crystal gomensing
Reports across Europe there are
commonwealth soldiers buried in scores
of cemeteries big and small here in a
tiny village in northern France a
uniquely Canadian tribute
Marta and ocean two local children learn
about our Remembrance Day Traditions
Frederick Russell didn't recite in
Flanders Fields but he did share the
story behind Lieutenant Colonel John
mcrae's powerful poem another story
shared with these young people not of a
Canadian pilot who went missing in
November 1942 after participating in
operation rhubarb Isabel Williams
imparting the stories of Fallen Canadian
soldiers is the goal of no stone left
alone these French youngsters are the
first in this area benefiting from the
Alberta initiative just as many Canadian
children have done they too placed
markers on the grave in tribute a sign
flight Sergeant William Donald Pagan is
not alone living in France the
sacrifices that Canadians made is
actually
very very concrete and touching and
living in a living in a in a rural area
in in Normandy I drive down the street
and I see Canadian flags somewhere or I
go I go by and I see a cemetery and
there's a Canadian inside Russell hopes
to expand the no stone left alone
program so French children will
understand Canada's contributions
Sergeant Pagan may be a stranger in this
beautiful foreign Village but he is
remembered
flowers are regularly placed on his
grave
Roland Simone says she does it because
if they had a child killed in war they
would be happy if people put flowers on
the grave and then there is Michelli
bear 80 years ago he was in this very
Cemetery the day the Canadian was
married
it kind of hurts my heart he says
because this young man came to defend us
and there he is a bear along with the
young children and local French leaders
all gathered to honor the Fallen
Canadian origin
the deputy mayor's son is also a pilot
and served in Afghanistan and so she has
taken a keen interest in Sergeant Pagan
mati Maison notes that he was barely 20
and calls what he must have seen
unimaginable the mayor says he was proud
when he was asked if tuvi lazif would
participate in no stone left alone
he called the ceremony very nice and
moving the mayor of was a very very
adamant at being involved and I know the
way things work around here is that the
mayor is going to talk to the mayor in
the village beside and say oh we had
this we had this uh we had this
organized the hope of a ripple of
remembrance by transmitting the story of
one Fallen Canadian honored in a tiny
French Village
Crystal gemancing Global News London
and that's global national for this
Saturday night I'm Farah Nasser
tonight's your Canada is the country's
longest pier in White Rock British
Columbia just outside of Vancouver until
tomorrow take care of yourselves and
each other good night
[Music]